up by the caravan down one more period  again  he delayed it too much and he allowed  nothing  reset oh my gosh that might be it now  because he got the reason i still okay  still okay wow  oh  good block  [Music]  back to the throne this time forward to  counter  yeah i wasn't looking for that one  being buying  nobody oh walk it out  block the dear life there oh man he's  got caught though  this is looking good for bk  i lost over half life  no counter no break rainbow drop no  break  oh boy rages  could have been game he waited  oh  yo  oh my god  not again  you can't even but down four three four  counter it's very rare to see that in  tournaments no yeah it was countered  there's a full commitment and speaking  of full commitment we've got rolling  death cradles here  look at the bar depleting  but this is oh my god we've got a throw  exhibition right now in the tournament  this is a true king player  [Music]  [Music]  you